I can't tell the difference
between my waking life and dreams
can i tell you a secret your mind is
a pendulum swinging between realities
your identities are not something to
be feared but something to be welcomed
this is the best worst day of my life
marvel studios moon knight now streaming
welcome back everyone this will be my full marvel moon
knight episode 4 trailer video there's a bunch
of easter eggs obviously they're hyping up a
whole bunch of stuff so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes we're also doing
a giveaway for disney plus memberships all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your predictions for the rest of the episodes
careful for spoilers for everything through
episode 3 if you haven't seen it yet we'll
be talking about everything that's happened so
far but at the end of episode 3 konchu lost his
verbal battle with part of their ruling council
of gods the enid there was a little confusion
about what was going on here why weren't all the
gods there they're supposed to be nine members
ruling over the other gods so remember there are
a ton of gods that are part of their egyptian
pantheon that khonshu comes from like khonshu was
born biologically to another god who's supposed
to be the leader of their pantheon his biological
sister is boss the panther goddess who gives all
of black panther in the panther tribe his powers
to make another connection to black panther 2 and
thor love and thunder because gore the god butcher
is going to be going around trying to kill all the
mcu gods the any of the egyptian gods here that
we're talking about in this series are just one
of the pantheons but for those of you asking
about it yes you are correct technically that
would make black panther or any black panther
at any given time in history the avatar of boss
there are a couple reasons why we only saw part of
the gods during this episode part of it's related
to some of the reasons that we saw during the thor
movies like every time thor did something bad and
got hauled in front of odin you didn't see every
single member of their asgardian pantheon there
are other people with god level powers there are
other members of thor's family that they haven't
introduced in the mcu yet part of it's practical
like they didn't want to have a thousand different
people all inside this chamber and they also imply
some of it through the story too like even though
konchu used some of his power through marc spector
like he was working through marc spector his
avatar to change the sky he couldn't do that just
by himself that's why at the end of the episode he
has to tell steven what to do like move your hands
like this because khonshu was doing it himself but
he had to do it through stephen grant while this
was happening most of the other prominent gods
that are part of their pantheon hate conchu
with a fiery passion they don't want to have
anything to do with him they don't want to pay
attention to him as much as possible so part of
the reason bost wasn't there part of the reason
the other members of the eniad weren't there
is because they don't respect him and another
big thing people were asking about that will
continue to be a thing in episode four episode
five even episode six is part of the reason why
it seemed like arthur harrow was able to deceive
people as powerful as the gods are supposed to
be was part of a misdirect it only seemed like
he was able to trick them during this trial as
hath horror explained before the trial started
in after the trial ended some of the gods know
exactly what's really going on and are just going
along with it for now for a couple of reasons
like i said most of the gods hate khonshu he's
kind of the black sheep of the family so to speak
and they've trapped him inside this other place
of the other dimension that they're in so remember
they're all trapped in this pocket dimension
in the episode they called it the overvoid but
in the comics they call it the other void it's
basically the same place so most of them don't
want to listen to anything he has to say like okay
you've lied to us so many times you've been so bad
we're not going to pay attention to you as much
as possible like the mcu god who cried sheep so
to speak an even bigger reason though is that most
of the gods are pretty lazy thor what do you know
is he asleep no no i'm pretty sure he's dead
as they've tried to show you in the episode so
far and they've showed you in the mcu just
kind of in general if you've read the thor
comics too this is a big thing during the gore
the god butcher storyline khonshu during the
episode even called the overvoid pocket dimension
where their forms are trapped very decadent but
remember technically all the god's true forms
are trapped in this place when they trapped him
in this traditional looking stone figure here this
is also designed on egyptian mythology there are a
lot of these types of stone figures that you see
during the end credit sequence with all the other
gods depicted there are a lot of them around this
place around the great pyramid of giza the avatar
of osiris talked to arthur harrow implying that
a lot of different people had been bound to this
place quote unquote before implying that lots
of gods and lots of prominent people in history
went through the same process that konchu just
went through but as stephen grant was reading in
episode 1 when the gods departed mankind and
went to the overvoid all their true essences
sort of transfer to this other pocket dimension
so when they say that they had already banished
konchu they basically just disallowed him from
hanging out with the other gods he's still trapped
outside the main mcu dimension it's just them
binding him in this stone here also on top of that
prevents him from communicating with his avatar or
granting him any of his power tying this back to
thor love and thunder like i said gore the goblins
going around killing all the mcu gods because he
thinks they only care about themselves and that's
basically what they tell you during this episode
they kind of confirm everyone's belief oh they
don't really care what's going on and that's why
they're kind of going along with this trial not
believing what khonshu says not thinking about
ahmet coming back because if they really wanted to
they could actually use their power to investigate
these claims but it will require a lot more effort
on their part but as they say they don't really
care about people that much we only let these
avatars here and give them part of their power to
observe what's going on which is why they
allow all this crazy stuff to go on like thanos
collecting all the infinity stones avengers
infinity war avengers endgame all the snaps
why they don't get involved with kang the
conqueror in the kang multiverse war because
it's happening inside the third mcu dimension
and they're off in this pocket dimension they're
basically protected from a lot of what's happening
the difference with gore the god picture going
around killing all the gods yes all these other
enid members here these gods that we see in the
episode would be on his list they'll explain this
a little bit better when the movie comes along
but gore the god butcher has found a cosmic weapon
that's allowed him to basically kill their essence
which is way harder to do than just killing
their physical form inside the mcu when they're
completely whole like ammit is trying to come back
into the mcu you could kill her physical form but
it'd be way more complicated to actually kill her
cosmic essence the same is true for characters
like odin like his essence is in their version
of valhalla which is kind of like the asgardian
pantheon's version of another pocket dimension and
also on the sly what i think is going on here what
they kind of imply is that some of the gods as
hathor explains probably know what's really going
on amid is really trying to come back into the mcu
and they're just going along with it for a couple
different reasons some of them because they're
selfish some of the other gods probably also want
to return to the mcu and become more powerful
themselves too but they're afraid to fight the
other gods who do want to stay in the pocket
dimension if it wasn't clear just because these
couple gods that you see in the episode are mad at
khonshu doesn't mean that they all like each other
most of the gods are all very selfish and they
have a loose alliance with each other even the
ones who are really shady want to avoid a god tier
avengers end game type of battle situation across
different dimensions because that's what would
happen if the gods went to war with each other
it would mean the end of all reality which is kind
of what we're threatened with during dr strange 2
multiverse of madness trying to end all of reality
in every single way possible with every single
super powerful character that's part of the reason
why gore the god butcher wants to get rid of all
the mcu gods like look they don't care about
us and they threaten all of reality so let's
just kill all of them but part of the idea in the
episode is that as the other gods right now hate
khonshu just like thor eventually redeemed himself
part of the gods probably want to give khonshu the
opportunity to redeem himself and rejoin them
we do see more footage of them traveling across
the sands of egypt actually finding ammit's tomb
where the coordinates led them steven grant inside
ammit's tomb yelling about how excited he is to
be doing all this indiana jones type of stuff
then there's footage of him fighting arthur harrow
and his men in the burial chamber and falling into
the water there's also footage of him opening
the sarcophagus with the body wrapped in this
traditional style now they're supposed to be
an ammit's tomb so these could be related to
her remains or they could belong to one of her
previous avatars there's also this purple energy
arcing out of the same great pyramid that we just
saw in episode three we were inside the actual
great pyramid of giza this might be arthur harrow
in acting as planned there's also this swirling
purple energy inside the great pyramid of giza
or inside this tomb so either he's using her
power or it's her god tier essence being released
the other thing that's going on here too with him
holding the action figure in this white space
that's also right out of the comics dude there
was a comic book run where it seemed like he had
been sent to a mental hospital because he couldn't
remember who he was or who he originally was and
whether or not moon knight was a real person too
he got so messed up that he didn't know which
personality was the original one and he didn't
know whether or not he just dreamt up konchu in
moon knight or if all that stuff really happened
he wound up finding out that konchu actually
orchestrated everything and it was all happening
inside his head and it was just the way
that konchu gave him to work it all out so
all these scenes of him freaking out inside this
white space with the real action figure of moon
knight is happening inside his head it's showing
you what it's like for the other personalities
when they're trapped inside the head and they're
not one of the active ones controlling the body
and i do believe the action figure they're using
for this you could actually go out and buy right
now or you will be able to buy like it's a marvel
legends toy that's actually being sold and even
though they are hyping up a big god tier war here
like arthur harrow versus moon knight both using
their avatar based powers and also the gods kind
of fighting each other they'll probably save that
to like the final episode but everyone post all
your theories in the comments below remember we're
only about halfway through the series there are
six episodes total my full moon knight episode 4
video will post next week there's a couple other
big marvel trailer videos that just dropped that
i'll do videos for i got a doctor strange 2 one
that'll post next congratulations marcus johns 25
you're the giveaway winner from my last big marvel
video please email me on the about page of my
channel so i can get your contact details usually
the best way to do that is on the desktop browser
everyone click here for my full moon knight
episode 3 video in easter eggs and click here
to learn about the connection between moon knight
black knight blade ghost rider inside the mcu
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!